it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
[Music]
should we do a little geek news [ __ ]
yeah man
how about those super pets huh leading
the box office this week dc league of
super pets
number one at the box office with a 23
million dollar opening last weekend it's
pretty impressive i didn't see it but
the trailers are adorable it looks
pretty cute yeah uh nope universal's
nope was number two at the box office
this week then marvel's thor
love and thunder minions rise of gru and
top gun maverick still hanging in the
top five yeah it's the summer top gun
man
maybe they should animated batgirl maybe
then they would have released it
the [ __ ] right are we talking about this
yeah it's
[ __ ]
shocking to me
on behalf of everyone who worked on that
show for months of their lives and gave
their energies and talents
spent 90 million dollars to make a piece
of work and i don't care
what they think it is in terms of how
successful the end result was or not
those people have earned a right to show
what they've done to people in my
opinion i may be wrong yeah uh
absolutely
um
but
time was in this business look you make
art for somebody else they pay for it
they get to do with it i get it i
understand i understand the economics of
it that being said there was a time when
like the [ __ ]
worst thing a director had to worry
about is like oh maybe they don't take
it the actual maybe go straight to video
now they've just added a new fear to the
mix which is like we may not release it
at all like and never in any form in
order for them to do what they're going
to do with this which is
write it down there's a window because
of the
the the uh merger between uh warner
brothers and discovery uh there's all
sorts of tax loopholes that they only
could take advantage of in this moment
in time when the merger is happening one
of them allows for them to literally
write off a 90 million dollar movie and
get a 20 million dollar write down which
seems to me like you're [ __ ] yourself
out of 70 million but whatever but in
order to do that the movie can never
see the light of day right because
it gets monetized instantly and then the
[ __ ] deal is off they have to give
all the tax money back and [ __ ] so this
ain't even a case of like you know
remember [ __ ] release the snyder cut
they were able to effectively get that
movie [ __ ] out there
they can nobody can do that with this
movie right in order for them to pull
off this [ __ ] business deal so
there's a guy named what is his name
david zasloff ah yeah
he's the dude that
was running discovery and in this merger
he was given
warner brothers and you know he's made a
bunch of [ __ ]
decisions in the last i mean we're
hearing about it in the last 48 hours
but clearly they've been going on for a
minute they're trying to cut three
billion dollars after the
the merger of the two companies there's
been enormous blood letting in terms of
human
resources and there's going to be more
because they're going after hbo max they
said they're laying off 70
of the development workforce and i like
i don't give a [ __ ] i got no skin in the
game like i i buy every streaming
service and [ __ ] cause i could write it
off because that's what i do for a
living it's part of my business is stuff
so i'm not one of the young person who
like goes like i got to figure out which
one i get them all because it's part of
what i do so i got no skin in the game
no no like you know this one over that
one i will say this hbo max isn't is a
superior product
to most streamers like they've got an
incredible selection the interface is is
perfect um there's always something to
[ __ ] watch i never put it on and go
like well [ __ ] nothing here um i
can't understand
why they would [ __ ] with this when what
to me it feels like they got the number
two streamer on the planet i agree right
below i don't i don't mean in terms of
subscriptions but like you know netflix
set the table and they're the gold
standard but like
hbo max i thought did an incredible job
in a brief period of time and when they
launched it was like haphazard and
[ __ ] they found there it was almost a
joke it was like oh they just one you
know wonder woman the second wonder
woman it's the only reason this thing
exists pretty much now it became this
great thing something else now a lot of
what they keep pointing out in the press
is a lot of the shows that you love
aren't hbo max shows they're hbo shows
that hbo max
also shows and those were two completely
separate entities oddly enough
so peacemaker of course being one of my
think peacemakers an hbo max show yeah
so it feels like based on all the
articles i read and then they did an
earnings call so they did articles about
that i ain't got no inside information
or anything just know what everybody
else knows but what i've seen i do know
one other thing which i do know an
inside thing and i'll tell you in a
second but based on the fact based on
the [ __ ] i read
the this new guy is just like
all dc is going to be theatrical right
he seems to have a bias against the
televised version of it they've been
said that they're going to model
themselves after what disney did with
marvel but i would submit to you that
marvel does television shows very
successful very [ __ ] expensive ones
on their own streaming network which
make people want to tune in yeah so
i know we'll never see it we gotta take
people's word for it and [ __ ] like that
but like apparently they said like
batgirl needed a lot of help and rather
than put more money into it was supposed
to be a 75 million movie it went to 90.
they decided [ __ ] it
and just they're not it's never going to
see the light of day yeah apparently
that's happening with a lot of [ __ ]
projects across
the boards uh a lot of people are
nervous about some of their favorite
projects whether they're going to
continue on a second season
because they've also kind of
de-prioritized
animation kids animation that haven't
said adult animation but a lot of people
are waiting to see if uh the venture is
with the venture brothers movie ever
[ __ ] gets made creators are having to
come out to reassure their fans oh don't
worry we're okay james gunn had to do
with peacemaker second season yeah and
uh um who else had to um the flash
producer said that that feature film's
still safe inexplicably that that is the
baffling thing it's like i don't give a
[ __ ] how bad the batgirl movie is
nobody in that movie very complicated or
have anything in their real life that
you have to market around but in the
flash movie we all know
there's a big
problem yeah flash is a super villain
that's the problem
flash is the reverse flash in real life
but um i was involved hbo max you know i
don't just say nice things about it for
this reason i was loving before they i
was involved with them but i i got paid
by these cats within the last year um
the good folks at berlanti reached out
to me two years ago and i've done a
bunch of episodes for
uh supergirl and flash
and so um
uh
sarah over there was like hey
uh hbo we're gonna do a new show with
hbo max
and i was like oh right on because
normally they do all their [ __ ] with cw
and this is like as hbo max was emerging
and i said what is it and she says the
dc comics show it's called strange
adventures
and strange adventures in the dc comics
is the title where um adam strange came
from yeah
they were using it as an anthology
series it was meant to be a dc comics
anthology series for
all of the characters that aren't
batman wonder woman
superman all the very famous characters
dc has a treasure trove of what they
call ip or what we just used to call
comic book characters
that they would love to like you know
get out there rather than just doing the
same stories over and over so they asked
me what i wanted to do and they gave me
a list of characters that i could choose
from and i chose two characters
on the list to create a story about and
it was uh jimmy olsen and the daily
planet
and bizarro
and uh me and eric carrasco was a good
friend of mine who wrote
the supergirl episodes i did and also
wrote on masters of the universe with me
for season one
uh him and i wrote this script
that
we were one
one story like when sarah pitched it to
me she was like we're doing strange
adventures
and we would love you to write and
direct one and i was like oh great and
having worked on the cw shows i assumed
it was like a three to four million
dollar production so i was like uh this
is great i said i normally don't like to
do [ __ ] big stuff you know i would
never do a superhero movie but i could
do you know three four million this is
my comfort range and [ __ ] and she goes
no it's more than that these are 16 to
20 million dollar shows per episode and
i was like what are you talking i said
can i talk to you people you're being
financially irresponsible like
look i like jimmy olsen but 20 million
dollars what are you nuts but that's
what they were going for everyone was
like [ __ ] we got to get the shows
that make people tune in like marvel so
the previous regime was just like we're
doing strange adventures so we were
writing one that i was gonna direct um
then there were four other creative
teams that were also writing uh some of
the characters that were up for grabs
were
uh ragman uh boston brand dead man
um uh who else i can't remember off the
top of my head but
um so it was
you know we turned in
three drafts of the [ __ ] script they
loved our [ __ ] script
um you know and we were waiting for the
other
scripts of the other creatives to come
in
before they were gonna figure out their
first season but we were on on deck for
the first one and the story was a
supermanless story
um which if anyone saw my masters of the
universe i know how to take the main
character out all together
make a lot of people happy in the
process everyone loves that too yeah
they like it do more of that so it was a
story about it was the it was
essentially the bizarro uh secret origin
and um they took
bizarro wound up taking jimmy olsen and
perry white that was my other character
to
bizarro world a version of bizarro world
and um he didn't appear as like me i'm
superman he appeared as a guy
in an old superman costume like like
george reeves or something like that and
slowly over the episode you know he was
a guy who essentially it was a
paranormal god in a different dimension
and into that dimension one day an
addition of the daily planet had been
sent through a teleporter an experiment
in metropolis it wound up into this
voidless dimension where this this being
like
tried to replicate the world of the
daily planet which includes stories
about superman and he set himself up as
superman so everybody there is like we
love superman but as soon as his back is
turned they're like oh boss
so uh the characters slowly over the
course of the episode uh would
you know the veneer would fall and uh
there was a rebellion that was growing
within this fake metropolis
where they would put backwards s's up on
the wall
to warn people about like he's not what
you think he is and that's where the
backwards s came from and then slowly
became over the course of the episode uh
bizarro and um and then came back to
metropolis and
fought outside the daily planet
the opening scene had a giant toy
soldier that was frozen outside the
daily planet because 20 minutes attacked
the day before
so that plays in the finale and [ __ ]
like that and then um at the end he
winds up doing something fairly heroic
like he comes as a monster but winds up
saving a [ __ ] child and finally gets
to be
the superman he always wanted to be and
then takes off and stuff like that
they're like i wonder if we'll ever see
him again and at the very end the ps
scene was like him uh at the edge of
nowhere you know just by by himself
and uh you know a pair of boots land
beside him and it's just like i hear you
did a really good thing
you know uh and where i come from and
stuff
and he was like hi i'm cal i'd like to
be your friend
he was like friend so it was really kind
of sweet kind of touching and [ __ ] like
that
uh i tell you all this uh and the entire
story just to tell you that the person
who is we didn't lock it in he wasn't
signed to a contract but the person that
we were pursuing to play barbara rosaro
was nicholas cage so
[Applause]
so oh i i cannot i can't i can't like
[ __ ] like i've been very fortunate in
life as i said earlier i don't know if
you're this but i'm buying a movie
theater so
things work out for me generally
speaking this was always a million to
one shot i couldn't believe they even
asked me to do it but me and eric wrote
like a terrific [ __ ] script um and it
was heading toward production like it
was it wasn't even like wish fulfillment
they this was something they were going
to do is there a connection between that
story and this what we're hearing about
hbo max yes because uh this happened i
said feared fearfully this was killed
definitely by the new regime no way
yeah absolutely it's not gonna happen um
i don't know this for a fact but i also
haven't heard anything about the green
lantern series that they were supposedly
doing i i wouldn't be surprised if that
was a casual t2 there were a lot of dc
oriented programs because that's what
the original the regime prior to this
new regime that warner brothers were now
warner brothers discovery was committed
all in to like look we got hbo max we're
gonna do [ __ ] dc stuff here we're
gonna do dc stuff in the movies and
they'll cross over and ship and this new
guy is just like no just for the movies
nothing for hbo max and it feels like
they announced in 2023
hbo max and discovery plus
are combining to become one app and hbo
max will cease to exist that ain't even
gonna be its name anymore yeah why the
[ __ ] do you build such a strong brand
and a great product only to literally
destroy this ain't cnn plus which this
same guy destroyed the week that he took
over they opened cnn plus didn't have
great numbers and [ __ ] but one week
later this dude killed it and they said
in the press it might have been spite
for the previous regime for starting
this before he took over he was like why
would you do such a [ __ ] thing and he
killed a multi-million dollar [ __ ]
initiative so if he was willing to kill
cnn plus it's really no long walk to be
like well we don't need this batgirl
movie either it's a really bad look
though i say never mind how much money
you could [ __ ] save but like i don't
mean to be this guy and i'm not you know
i know a lot of people online are like
go whoa go broke and [ __ ] like that but
like it's an incredibly bad look to
cancel the latina batgirl movie
you know what i'm saying like yeah
i i don't know i don't get when ezra
miller is out holding people up at
gunpoint
i i don't give a [ __ ] if the movie was
absolute [ __ ] dog [ __ ] man they they
spent and it was i guarantee you it
wasn't the two directors who directed
that movie did a couple episodes of ms
marvel yeah and it was a wonderful
[ __ ] show you know great looking and
they had more money to do batgirl than
they had to do an episode of ms marvel
and stuff so and warner brothers should
know they make a ton of shitty superhero
movies to make a lot of money and
yes and also like not for nothing but
like how how could it be
i i love all the cw shows but the cw
shows like show their budgetary
constraints
and the big complaint they said here is
like well it wasn't big enough to be a
[ __ ] theatrical release so you know
it looked too cheap because it was a 90
million movie how do you make a cheap
looking 90 million dollar [ __ ] movie
but if it looked anything if it looked
like slightly better than an episode of
you know [ __ ] arrow
why couldn't we have seen that right and
it feels like there's more than just
like we're gonna save
20 million dollars like i i don't know
man it's
they also killed the
the super girl movie they were working
on the upset as well so i and the wonder
twins it never really pissed me off
so i wanted to see that was the thing
and jaina or whatever the [ __ ] their
names are we cheered when he killed that
we were like that's good [ __ ]
thinking and then he started you know
going after [ __ ] we wanted and and now
then they came for us exactly [ __ ] we
should have spoke up in the beginning
but it's uh crazy man i got like don't
feel bad for me i got paid me and eric
made a lot of money to write that script
if i used it to buy a theater you could
buy a movie theater with that kind of
money a little bit actually a little bit
but uh but yeah it could have been a
cool thing so we're talking about taking
over to dc doing it as a comic book you
know because oh [ __ ] you took the time
to write the script so it's like i just
give it to an artist and have them draw
it but yeah man it feels like
what was once to me a very promising
future of like oh [ __ ] we're going to
see a bunch of dc stuff on hbo max more
dc stuff than we were going to see
theatrically including [ __ ] like strange
adventures
gone all of it's just [ __ ] gone now
got a call the other day from eric
before all the story broke and he was
just like strange adventures officially
dead i was like what the [ __ ] are you
serious i mean i know we hadn't heard
from him in a little while but i guess
this goes part and parcel with the new
moves that they were doing with the with
the um the what's the guy's name's oslov
zazzle
but uh good lord uh i thought
you know our the strange adventures
being a casualty kind of made sense to
me i'm like nobody necessarily knows
these characters sounded like an
expensive show
who the [ __ ] don't know batgirl right
and more importantly like with all due
respect to everyone in the cast i'm sure
they did a great job
michael [ __ ] keaton came back as
batman and now we're not gonna [ __ ]
see that people are gonna tune in just
for that fact and it's starting to smell
like we're not gonna see him ever
like i wouldn't be surprised if
i know they said like flash is safe but
i would not be surprised if this was
them testing the water to be like let's
see what they say if we [ __ ] cancel
batgirl and if it doesn't go too badly
maybe we just [ __ ] cancel flash
because it's problematic how are they
gonna market that movie without like a
leading uh actor to go out on the road
and do press and stuff without people
being like uh
what have you been up to lately yeah i
got a bunch of questions yeah none of
them have to do with the movie
when you broke into that folks house
good god
yeah so i i don't know what's going on
over there but like
it's tough to sometimes to be a dc fan
and
in the movie you know especially when
they announced oh we were going to have
a big a 10-year plan and we're going to
we're going to roll out these films and
tie them all together and i was like
they said i've heard this before exactly
they said that once before and they
showed us a plan once of all the movies
that were coming out remember there's
going to be a cyborg movie i think that
was supposed to come out before the
flash movie back in the day yeah we're
right around it so yeah you know i don't
know but i also saw a follow-up report
that the
after that call
the stocks dropped oh yeah they're
hurting dramatically like people weren't
you know inspired by that call they
weren't like these are good business
decisions bunch of people were like what
the [ __ ] are you doing so who knows
we'll see what happens but
they then there's a new guy over there
his new sheriff in town and things are
certainly different
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith
[Music]